you have six dozen tattoos on your body
do you think in some way the tattooing
was a way to take control of your own
look and your own body I've always liked
a good face tattoo we were talking about
Gans spank he was the first face tattoo
I've ever saw it was the star he had
like a little star right there how old
were you when you got your first face
tattoo 19 19 I think it was a little uh
smiley face that everyone thinks is
marshmallow yeah that's what I thought
it was when I get a tattoo I I always
look at it afterwards and I go [__] this
thing looks really big I didn't think it
was going to look this big it's kind of
jarring at first and I and I'm like oh I
think I just made a mistake and what
happens when you first walk into a
tattoo place don't they say to you
listen we got to make sure you're not
high we got to make sure that you're
making this decision on your own like
like for years tattoo dudes would not
put a tattoo on anyone's face they just
it was forbidden now if I went into a
tattoo parlor and I was like hey man I
need a face tattoo like pronto they'd be
like all right let's [__] go let's do
[__] right um but I I feel like you
know if I didn't first off if I wasn't
um a singer and second off if I didn't
already have some it would be um a whole
different deal uh but yeah I don't know
it's always bigger than you
think that it was but you just kind of
Let It Rock I mean you've already done
it if you look at a t tattoo that you
got and you're like oh [__] dude that's
so
big uh Michael Scott that's what she
said
but it's already too late so you just
got to be like oh that's the way it is
that's just the way it is when you
walked into the place at 19 they go like
dude we got to we got to make sure
you're okay like we got to we got to
really talk this over or they just did
it no I I think by then I had already
had um a couple songs out and I get it I
I think we did it at the show and I was
like oh I was hammered drunk and I was
like oh I really need a face T too like
right now and then we did
it